wow what a day I mean such a bloody day  so many decisive games and almost no  draws yeah  yeah we had we had everything we had uh  some great games also this unbelievably  nice combination  and um  some some completely dominant  performances right Prague 3-0 Magnus  three zero  and some yeah  two and a half half yeah  also vastly against our Junior and  that's what we talked about in the break  yeah that if Wesley starts to win  it's it's a bad news for for the  concurrency yeah for for his opponents  because  I have tremendous faith in investing and  that's it Liam resigns a new passport  appeared and that's it for today I mean  uh the games the matches have been  settled I'm believing that we will be  hearing a Prague interview right now  from